good morning everyone if you think your
business idea is failing and you're on
the verge of quitting I'm gonna share
with you a clip from Tim Ferriss that I
hope will motivate you to keep going I
think failure would be a big piece even
though I view failure differently than I
think many people I view it as a
feedback mechanism but if you look at
even let's say the 4-hour workweek
didn't start off called the 4-hour
workweek it was also turned down by 26
out of twenty-seven publishers and
hopefully pretty soon it'll be
celebrating four years
unbroken on the New York Times
bestseller list and I like to whenever
possible illustrate those failures
because people will everyone will face
failure or from mistakes and those are
the divergent points from which they can
either go in a good direction or a bad
direction and I want to illustrate that
oftentimes the finish line is only a
hundred feet from where you stand but it
might seem that it's a hundred miles
away so my take on this is a lot of
entrepreneurs quit too soon you quit too
early you have a great idea you have a
great product you have a great service
but it's just not hitting the mark yet
and you quit before you can really let
that momentum take off for you and I
know because that was me I was a guy who
told my business partner that I quit and
luckily he I had something in me that
made me keep going but when I told my
business partner that I quit it was the
worst day of my life you know I had the
tears kind of my eyes and my nose and I
just felt like I was totally worthless
and everything that I put my energy into
here just was not working out and and I
felt like I added no value to the world
that was the worst day of my life but
very shortly after that I turned the
business around
I started getting big clients I started
landing international distributors and
within three years I had gone from
making $300 a month to having my
business being acquired by a major
company the key thing is when you're
faced with a lot of failure it's not to
give up but it's to change because if
you keep doing the same thing you're
doing it over and over and over again
you're probably going to get the same
results so look at what that failure is
leading you to and see what can I change
in my
start getting better results so from my
business it was modeling success I
learned from Bill Gates and how he
started Microsoft and applied his
strategies to help my business grow for
Tim's business maybe he had to change
the title of his book to start getting
some attention and traction for your
business you've got to take the feedback
that you're getting from the failure and
pour it back into your business to make
a change to start getting better results
because so so so so so often just by
making a few changes to your business
and your approach you can start seeing
dramatic results in your company so if
you're seeing a lot of failure with your
business right now I'd encourage you to
try to take that failure as feedback to
think about how you can make your
business better instead of throwing in
the towel and giving up because more
often than not you're closer than you
think you are to achieving your dream
belief thank you guys so much for
watching
my question of the day for you is what
keeps you motivated when you are feeling
when you're struggling you have a hard
time to keep going what keeps you
motivated to put in one more day one
more day one more day leave it in the
comments I'd really love to hear from
you of course if you like this video and
you want to see more don't forget to
subscribe to the channel and to the
newsletter have a fantastic day and I
hope you'll join me again tomorrow at 7
a.m.
Eastern with another video to start your
day off on the right foot